a decorated Navy SEAL is expected back
in court today after being acquitted of
the most serious charges in a war crimes
trial a military jury cleared Special
Operations Chief Edward Gallagher of
premeditated murder yesterday he still
faces sentencing on a charge of posing
with a militants body as Jonathan
Vigliotti reports the jury at the Naval
Base in San Diego deliberated for about
eight hours I thank God my legal team my
wife Navy SEAL Chief Edward Gallagher
says he's grateful he's been exonerated
for the most serious charges against him
he walked out of military court Tuesday
with his wife Andre up by his side I was
feeling like were finally vindicated
after being terrorized by the government
that my husband fought for for two
decades in the war on terror during
Gallagher's two-week trial seven seals
from his platoon testified that he
stabbed an Isis captive in Iraq more
than two years ago the team seen here in
an Iraqi news report was injured in an
airstrike the prosecution said Gallagher
proved his own guilt with photos and
text messages including one in which he
allegedly bragged got him with my
hunting knife but in a stunning twist
another medic who was granted immunity
told the court he killed the prisoner by
holding his thumb over his tracheal tube
until he quit breathing this should
never have gotten to a trial the way
that it did defense lawyers call the
case a mutiny led by junior seals trying
to oust a demanding chief what the Navy
needs to learn is that before they
charge somebody they do a proper
investigation
Andrea Gallagher says her husband's case
raises fundamental questions about the
military justice system I think that
this vindication I hope will be a lesson
learned to everybody that we need to
uphold innocent till proven guilty due
process and we need to afford the
benefit of the doubt to our war heroes
who we send over there to fight these
evils
Gallagher has already spent more than
200 days in prison he's not expected to
serve any more time but Tony he could be
demoted which would impact his pension
and benefits all right Jonathan thank
you very much